domingo de referendos en europa
empezando con la minúscula república de
san marino este micro estado enclavado
en italia votó con una abrumadora
mayoría a favor de la legalización del
aborto anulando así una ley de
1865 el 77 por ciento de los votantes
respaldó la propuesta de permitir la
interrupción del embarazo hasta las 12
semanas de gestación y después en caso
de que la vida de la madre esté en
peligro o que el feto sufra una
malformación grave jacques santer al
77% decir hemos ganado con un aplastante
77% para el sí increíble simplemente
increíble no esperábamos bueno si lo
esperábamos pero no tan alto es
increíble increíble
continuando con los derechos humanos
suiza adoptó este domingo el matrimonio
entre personas del mismo sexo
un 64% de los suizos se pronunció a
favor de esta iniciativa que permitirá
que estas parejas puedan adoptar hijos o
tener acceso a las técnicas de
reproducción asistida en el caso de las
mujeres se han visto las estrías es un
día histórico para nosotros y para suiza
es un gran paso adelante algo que hemos
estado esperando durante años esta
iniciativa se inició en 2013 tuvimos que
esperar ocho años para que se votara y
aquí esto es un gran si él se come
mcgoey del lado de alemania los votantes
de la capital berlín además de votar por
la composición del nuevo parlamento y
por su legislatura local participaron en
una consulta popular para expropiar las
grandes promotoras inmobiliarias él se
obtuvo un 56% y el no un 39% como
resultado de una campaña para poner
parte del parque de viviendas privadas
bajo gestión pública con el fin de
regular mejor los precios que se han
disparado en los últimos años el
resultado no es vinculante pero la nueva
alcaldesa la socialdemócrata francisca
ifai
declaró que debía respetarse el
resultado del referéndum al tiempo que
reiteró su oposición a las
expropiaciones